In this video, we're going to talk about how to create a Blueprint in Unreal in which
we can populate it with Static Meshes and to be able to edit them quickly and duplicate
them and make changes all across the board.
So let's get started.
So first we're going to create a Blueprint Actor, and let me show you how this works.
We also have a step-by-step in the notes, which takes you through some of these details.
So let's go and do that.
In Unreal, we have a seed here, and we want to be able to maybe make a set of stalactites
type of objects sticking through the ground.
I'm probably using that word incorrectly.
There's stalagmites, stalagdites, I forget which one sticks up and which one sticks down.
But in this case, there are spikes.
So let's just say spikes.
So these spikes, I'm going to have different versions of them, and I want to be able to
actually change and edit them and not only change them individually, but also maybe change
them all across the board.
And it's actually pretty simple to do that.
Unreal itself has an amazing instancing system within it in which you can duplicate things,
and it really does look at the last one, and it allows for a quick calculation of that
object.
Now it does require a draw call, so many times emerging is more ideal.
But when we're using Blueprints, it allows us to house different items within there,
duplicate them, and maybe even change them all across the board so that Blueprint instance
is being able to affect all different ones or separate ones as you work.
So let me show you how to do that.
It's actually not that difficult.
So we're going to go to our Blueprints here.
I'm going to make a brand new NT Blueprint.
You can select an object and say, hey, I'm going to make this instantly into a Blueprint.
The only disadvantage you get with this is you can lose some of your scale, rotation,
and translation within how's within that Blueprint.
I like to be able to have the option of it still being there plus having it here within
the details.
So I like to do it here, do it raw.
So I'm going to go in and right click here, and I'm going to create a new Blueprint class.
We'll just choose Actor because Actor is the most diversified.
So if we needed to program right within this and edit it and make maybe special features,
maybe you want to control how they work, maybe you want them to be more random, we can do
so if we have an empty Actor.
So it allows us to use our Blueprint programming scripting language to be able to make it more
robust.
So this is the most diversified.
So we're going to hit on Actor.
We're going to call this Blueprint underscore Spire control, and you can call it whatever
you want if you're following along.
So I'm going to double click on this.
We're going to pop this up.
And what we want to do is add a component.
So component we want to add is our Spire.
Unreal is pretty smart.
In older versions of Unreal, you would do add a component and have to hunt it down.
But many times if you haven't already selected, you can add a component and it'll actually
recognize the one that you have selected, but not all the time.
So sometimes there is a little bit of refresh.
So we'll have to do Static Mesh.
And you'll see here we can do an Static Mesh.
We want to do this one, not the Instance one because these are great too.
They just give you a lot more options.
If you have things already, say you've merged stuff such as a hierarchal instance Static
Mesh, it will actually allow you to populate it.
But we just want to do a Static Mesh in general.
It's fine.
And that works just fine because we don't have thousands of these.
And if we did have a ton of them, we'd want to probably lean more towards foliage at that
point.
So I'm going to go Static Mesh here.
I'm going to call this Spire 01.
And we'll hit Enter.
Now if we go to our, now we're not going to create anything within our Event Graph.
And we have that option that we can.
But you'll see with this Spire selected, we have a Static Mesh component ready to go.
If I wanted to be able to program in here some more, I can grab my Static Mesh from
my, say it's populated in my environment.
And I can drag that Static Mesh reference in here if I needed to.
But we're not going to go that far into the weeds here.
So I'm going to go in here and grab that Spire.
I can grab any Spire that I want.
And I'll grab this first one here.
And you'll see that it's now connected within our Blueprint.
I'm going to go to my Viewport and we'll see that Spire is there.
And that's perfect.
That's exactly what we need.
So we need to actually make sure we also have the correct material for him.
So you'll see default material came in when we brought him in because we built this guide
before Mixer had the option to be able to export immediately.
So what we can do is grab that material that we need for this Spire.
And we're going to connect it to him.
Now we're just going to grab one in the scene.
I'm going to hit the magnifying glass.
I'm going to cheat a little bit.
And we're going to grab this and just drag it into this particular character.
That's perfect.
So I'm cheating a little bit and that's fine just to speed things up.
I'm going to rotate this.
It's good cheating.
And I'm going to now hit my Spacebar.
And I'm going to set this rotation to a world and keep my finger on the Alt key and drag
and duplicate just one more within this Blueprint environment.
So let me hit Alt drag this through.
Actually I need to create another one.
So sorry I was thinking in the Viewport.
So we don't want to do that.
What I do here and just do another static mesh.
So what you got not enough coffee.
You can grab a static mesh and we'll call this guy.
And we don't want this guy to be parented underneath him.
So we want to make it separate.
We don't want to attach it in any way so we can move him and move him right on top there.
And it'll actually separate this.
Let's give it a name.
We'll call this static mesh 02.
Or 02.
That's perfect.
There we go.
And we'll move this one over.
Oh it's not populated yet.
Let's go and populate it with the same static mesh.
Spire I should say.
So what happens when you attack and move things around.
Grab the same material.
Put it in there.
Rotate it a bit so it looks a little bit different here.
I hit spacebar and accident.
It took into the material and that's fine.
Let's rotate this though a little bit more.
There we go.
It looks a little bit different material wise.
Rotate that down.
Let's scale that down a bit.
So let's switch that to vocal.
We'll scale that down just a tad.
And we'll move this one a little bit past there.
Make them kind of reflect on top of each other.
And we'll do one more.
Just for the heck of it.
We'll do this guy here.
And if you need to you can also duplicate it.
So I just showed you how you can load them if you need it to be unique.
But you can also duplicate it there.
So with that duplication selected.
Then I'll move this one over.
And that's a little bit faster.
But I wanted to show you that you can also load them one more time.
Just in case you might have missed that the first time.
Move that down.
And let's actually scale this one up.
Every time I look at this it reminds me of chicken fingers.
I'm not sure why.
So we'll go ahead and grab this here.
And move this up there.
Alright so just a little quick clump of spires here.
We can play with.
Cool.
So this fellow we can hit compile.
We can find out where he's at by hitting browse.
There's our new spire set.
That we've made.
And this is the cool thing about the power of this.
So I can move this spires in here.
And I can scale them down.
We can also do that within the blueprint itself.
So I'll just do it here.
Scale that down.
My scale's a little funky so let's go and change that real quick here.
There we go. One more fluid.
And now I have a set of spires that I can control.
Let me control so you won't see it too far.
Set of spires that I can place in the world any way that I want.
I'll go to my camera here.
You can see it's a false set here.
There we go.
And the cool thing about this.
Is now I can pull this here.
And I can hit alt and move this over.
Rotate this one.
About one, two.
And we'll do this on an object basis rotation.
So let's do that.
Kind of rotate.
It's kind of the same thing.
It's all good.
And then we'll move this over.
And.
Go back to the world.
We can rotate this any way that we desire.
Give it a little bit of a different angle.
And I can change these to make them individual.
So with this one set here I can simply go into one.
I can go into the blueprint itself.
And I can change the angle.
And I can go into the blueprint itself.
And edit it here.
And the cool thing about this is if you want to change all of them you can.
So I can hit the space bar.
Let me move just a tad here.
You can see it moving real time.
Let me shrink this down just a little bit more.
So you can see this actively happening.
Because it's getting cut off.
So as I rotate this you'll see both of them change.
And that's actually kind of nice.
So if you want to say hey I need to change all of them.
You can make a quick change for that.
And I can hit compile.
And it'll update them all on the fly.
But the benefit also of doing this is the fact that I can go in here.
Select this particular blueprint.
And I can go individually here.
And I can also rotate them without affecting the other ones.
Which is really convenient to be able to do that.
Scale it down and you'll notice we're keeping this blueprint still unique.
So you can have a bunch of these in the scene.
Do some quick editing.
And it allows you to be able to control and edit things the way that you want.
And this is a really great way to maintain your scenes look and feel.
And I kept it pretty simple.
This can actually go for houses.
If you need a door open it over here.
But they're all the same type of copy of each other.
And all you're doing is changing them quickly on the fly.
Either as a whole or individually.
And keeping them kind of like in a group setting with the other ones.
And you can also do that with the other ones.
And I can also do that with the other ones.
And keeping them kind of like in a group setting with these blueprints.
It's really great.
And it allows you to add some more functionality.
So if I wanted to make this more random.
Which is some of our other classes.
Which talks about the introduction to blueprints for virtual production.
You can actually go in there and make it more random.
So it rotates randomly as you move things around.
And shovel things around.